[Musik]
viel protest eine sorge extremisten
könnten die demos gegen korona auflagen
für ihre zwecke nutzen warnen politiker
aus bund und ländern
vier anschläge eine festnahme ein
selbsternannter es kämpfe aus bayern
besteht die angriffe auf türkisch
stämmige ladenbesitzer zwei corona fälle
viele fragen die ansteckungen beim
zweitligisten dynamo dresden stellen das
comeback des profifußballs auf die probe
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zu unserem
nachrichtenüberblick am sonntag die
proteste gegen die einschränkungen in
der korona krise haben die politik
alarmiert denn was sich da an unmut
zusammenbraut geht teilweise weit über
jede sachliche kritik an den maßnahmen
zur eindämmung des virus hinaus so als
sei die solche nur ein vorwand der
regierenden um freiheiten und rechte der
bevölkerung zu beschneiden
wie damit umgehen die debatte darüber
kommt gerade in fahrt christiane hübsche
5000 in stuttgart 3000 in münchen gut
1000 waren es gestern auf dem berliner
alexanderplatz allen lockerungen zum
trotz wächst der widerstand gegen die
anti virus maßnahmen protest oft
deutlich über der aktuell erlaubten
teilnehmerzahl und von der politik nicht
mehr zu ignorieren
was mich allerdings sehr erschreckt ist
das offensichtlich jegliche
hygienemaßnahmen außer acht gelassen
werden bei sehr vielen teilnehmern und
da muss ich sagen das finde ich schon
sehr egoistisch und auch
unverantwortlich
ich will niemandem vorschreiben mit wem
er bei solchen demonstrationen zusammen
auftritt denn wäre alles gemeinsam
protestiert ist schwer zu erfassen
arbeitslose gastronomen alleinerziehende
aber oft auch links und rechtsextreme
impfgegner verschwörungs erzähler das
müsst ihr die meinungsfreiheit aushalten
so winfried kretschmann bei berlin
direkt
dass alle menschen einer demokratie
einer meinung sind das ist einfach
niemals gott sei dank der fall und es
ist ihr gutes recht dagegen zu
protestieren auch thüringens
ex-ministerpräsident kemmerich von der
fdp lief gestern ohne mundschutz bei
einer demo in gera mit dabei auch
fdp-vertreter sein parteichef lindner
kritisiert ich habe dafür kein
verständnis
andere fordern konsequenzen
offensichtlich sucht er auch die
physische nähe jetzt zur afg und allen
verschwörungstheoretikern es ist jetzt
genug er schadet der freien
demokratischen partei und allen die für
diese arbeiten kämpfen
und insofern bin ich der meinung dass er
aus der partei austreten sollte per
video entschuldigt sich thomas kemmerich
es sei nie seine absicht gewesen der afg
oder verschwörungstheoretikern eine
plattform zu bieten
er sehe aber ein dass er genau das getan
habe das ganze interview mit
ministerpräsident kretschmann können sie
gleich in berlin direkt sehen zum corona
virus selbst da zeigt sich in
deutschland aktuell keine eindeutige
entwicklung einerseits ist die
ansteckungsrate laut
robert-koch-institut wieder über die
kritische schwelle gestiegen auf 1,1
damit steckt ein infizierter
durchschnittlich mehr als einen weiteren
menschen an
andererseits gibt es bei den
neuinfektionen ein trend nach unten
im schnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich 910 menschen pro tag
angesteckt fünf regionen in deutschland
liegen aktuell über der obergrenze für
neuinfektionen
was sind die ursachen für die
gestiegenen fallzahlen und wie reagieren
die verantwortlichen antworten darauf
finden sie in unserer zdf heute app in
europa hat das virus am schlimmsten die
briten getroffen mit bereits knapp
32.000 toten erste london corona nicht
ernst genug genommen dann auf harte
beschränkungen gesetzt jetzt soll es
einen vorsichtigen mittelweg geben den
premier johnson am abend der bevölkerung
vorstellen will
fragen wir diana zimmermann in london
diana wie wird dieser mittelweg denn
aussehen
der mittelweg ähnelt eher einem
schlingerkurs boris johnson wird
vermutlich ankündigen dass der momentan
geltende regierungskurs bleibt zu hause
in den slogan bleibt wachsam abgewandelt
wird das sorgt schon im vorfeld für viel
ärger die opposition sagt der neue
slogan sei gefährlich uneindeutig und
die regierungen von schottland wales und
nordirland sagen gar sie werden diesen
kurs nicht mittragen angesichts so goa
todeszahlen sei es viel zu früh
entwarnung zu signalisieren
konkret allerdings bleibt auch boris
johnson wohl sehr vorsichtig die briten
sollen ab morgen mehr als einmal aus dem
haus dürfen pro tag
sie sollen wieder arbeiten gehen so sie
denn am arbeitsplatz auf abstand achten
können
das war es dann schon mit den neuen
großen freiheiten auch die gartencenter
dürfen wieder aufmachen
das ist hier tatsächlich sehnlichst
erwartet danke für die informationen
nach london diana zimmermann war das für
viele menschen in der türkei ist heute
ein besonderer tag konkret für alle über
65 denn die müssen sich einer längeren
und strengeren ausgangssperre fügen als
alle anderen altersgruppen
jetzt wurde sie zum ersten mal gelockert
wenn auch nur für vier kostbare stunden
rausgehen luft schnappen und dabei einen
hauch normalität nach hause nehmen jörg
brase berichtet gina und netzwerk und
sie dürfen heute endlich mal wieder raus
nach 51 tagen das rentnerpaar hat sich
gefügt als ihnen die regierung ab märz
verbot auf die straße zu gehen so ist
das heute für sie wie ein feiertag
ich fühlte mich wie neugeboren das
wetter ist auch sehr schön
ich bin total überrascht die türkische
regierung sieht das ausgangsverbot als
besten schutz für die älteren die
durften nur heute für vier stunden raus
während alle anderen zu hause bleiben
mussten nur kein risiko eingehen das
verstehen auch schöner und nässe sie
halten abstand selbst zur tochter und
den enkeln die nur ein stockwerk
darunter wohnen
wir gehören beide zur risikogruppe
deshalb besuchen wir auch die kinder
nicht wenn wir uns vermissen rufen wir
sie über what's up an obwohl sie nur ein
stockwerk unter uns wohnen
der erste monat war ganz okay aber jetzt
im zweiten tue ich mich echt schwer
ich will raus mein körper will raus aber
mein kopf sagt nein
doch sie müssen vorerst weiter
durchhalten nur diese strengen maßnahmen
sagt die türkische regierung seien der
grund dass die türkei mit rund 3700
corona opfern bislang recht gut durch
die krise gekommen ist
im oberbayerischen waldkraiburg östlich
von münchen gab es in den vergangenen
wochen gleich mehrere anschläge gegen
leeden türkischstämmiger inhaber nun ist
klar
der mutmaßliche täter ist es anhänger
und hatte noch schlimmeres vor
bei seiner festnahme fand die polizei
zahlreiche rohrbomben wird er seine wald
berichtet etwa drei wochen lang hat eine
anschlagserie im oberbayerischen
waldkraiburg die eigens eingerichtete
soko prager beschäftigt am freitag haben
die ermittler einen jungen mann
festgenommen der die taten gestanden hat
ein 25-jähriger deutscher staatsbürger
mit türkischen eltern
er hat in den letzten jahren zunehmend
sich richtung hass gegen türkische
mitbürger entwickelt und hat auch eine
erklärt der sympathie für den
islamischen staat gezeigt
bei der durchsuchung seiner wohnung in
waldkraiburg wurden fast zwei dutzend
funktionsfähige rohrbombe gefunden
eine scharfe waffe und etwa zehn kilo
chemikalien für sprengstoff der
mutmaßliche täter gestand vier anschläge
gegen türkische geschäfte in
waldkraiburg seit mitte april beim
brandanschlag gegen einen türkischen
gemüseladen wurden sechs menschen
verletzt
dem 25 jährigen wird schwerer
brandstiftung gefährliche
körperverletzung und versuchter mord in
27 fällen vorgeworfen
es besteht natürlich anfangsverdacht
bezüglich des tatbestands der
vorbereitung einer schweren
staatsgefährdenden gewalttat da müssen
wir die frage stellen warum hat er in
der massivität rohrbombe hergestellt zu
welchem zweck zu welchem zweck hatte die
berater gehabt die ermittler gehen nun
der frage nach wer dem mutmaßlichen
täter der noch weitere anschläge geplant
hatte die waffe verkauft hat und ob es
mitwisser unterstützer oder gar mittäter
gab
kommendes wochenende soll der fußball in
deutschlands stadien wieder rollen
doch nicht für zweitligist dynamo
dresden zwei weitere spieler wurden
positiv auf corona getestet und der
tabellenletzte muss komplett für 14 tage
in quarantäne
der fall wirft fragen auf für den
gesamten bundesliga notbetrieb stefan
beer
für die deutsche fußball liga stellen
die dresdner quarantänemaßnahmen die
geplante fortsetzung der saison mitten
in der korona pandemie nicht in frage
für die zweite liga wo eben 81 spiele
anstehen bedeutet das für den moment
das zwei spiele von dynamo dresden
vorerst nicht gespielt werden können wir
werden sehen wie wir damit umgehen wir
ändern momentan aber nicht das ziel
sondern wenn überhaupt die pläne und das
ziel bleibt weiterhin die saison zu ende
zu bringen
wie viele weitere ausfälle der geplante
spielbetrieb bis ende juni durch
ähnliche vorgänge wie in dresden
verkraften kann konnte christian seifert
im aktuellen sportstudio des zdf gestern
nicht abschätzen kann ich ihnen momentan
nicht sagen es hängt immer davon ab wann
das stattfinden würde und wie viel zeit
sie theoretisch noch haben eine saison
weiter zu führen
die zeit könnte also knapp werden bei zu
vielen spiel verschiebungen durch zu
viele infektionsfälle wie in dresden
die bundesliga kann trotz corona konzept
jederzeit wieder zum stillstand kommen
heute ist muttertag da möchte man sich
natürlich ganz fest in den arm nehmen
sollte man in diesen zeiten aber nicht
umso schöner wenn zumindest ein besuch
möglich ist wie hier in einem
seniorenheim in münster unter strengen
hygiene auflagen und hinter plexiglas
immerhin und blumen gibt es natürlich
auch was wir noch bieten können ist der
blick aufs wetter und star regnet es
morgen vom südwesten bis in den osten
kräftig die schneefallgrenze sinkt bis
600 meter im nordwesten sonnen im
südosten nachmittags gewitter bei 7 bis
22 grad
das war es von uns danke dass sie dabei
waren